I genuinely mourn who I could have been
like the person that I could have been if I didn't have like ADHD
just making a video about it
and I didn't realize how heavily my life has been impacted by this thing
like every aspect of my life
like my depression
my you know weight
my you know movement
my desire to get out of bed is all impacted by my ADHD
I I can't communicate with my friends like I
I'm so bad at like
literally just texting my friends back
I don't know what it is
my brain can't do it unless I'm medicated
but first of all
I haven't been able to get my medication in literally
months because of the shortage
like I went to CVS last week and
and my pharmacist was like
we have a list five pages long of people who can't get their vyvance
like it's not just you
and every time I take my meds I'm like
reminded of like
what it's like to be able to like
function like a person
like having ADHD means that you're fighting with your brain all the time
it's like my brain is like
on self destruct mode all the time
and like ah like
there are people that just like
don't have to fight with themselves to do basic daily tasks
and it's just so frustrating
and ADHD is literally so debilitating
and I would genuinely not wish this on my worst enemy
and I know like
social media like
kind of has diminished what ADHD is or like
has made it oh
I'm just like a quirky
manic pixie dream girl
like no like this
like this is the most disabling thing about my life
more so than being a large fat person
my life is more so impacted by my ADHD
I have such bad executive functioning issue
I'm so bad at doing anything alone
not because like I it it it
my brain literally is in like
buffer mode 90% of the day unless I see someone
and I just
I wonder what would have happened if a
I got diagnosed earlier I
I love my parents
and I'm not blaming them for this
but like they were told when I was in preschool that my
my teacher thought that I had ADHD
but first of all
my parents are immigrants
so like that
they don't believe in that
but also like
growing up as a girl
the way that ADHD presents in US
is different than the way that it presents in boys
so like so many girls don't get diagnosed at a young age with ADHD
and I just a
like wonder what the trajectory of my life would have been had I gotten like
a diagnosis early on and like
had tools to
to exist because now
in my adulthood like
I feel like I'm just catching up to all the things that I like
failed at in my childhood
like especially school as like
I genuinely crave and desire to learn
but school was so hard for me
like I just I
it was so difficult for me
and I didn't understand why
it was so hard for me
compared to everyone
I just thought I was lazy like I was
I just thought that I was lazy
like maybe I was
but it wasn't completely that
god I'm sorry I'm crying
I'm just like uh
but like now I know
it was literally just my brain
like when I was younger
one of my favorite things in the entire world was to read
and then I was like
I was like 12
I think when I was 12
I read maybe 200 books
and then school started getting more difficult
and I had to do my readings for school
but I like my brain couldn't do that
so then I felt guilty reading books
so for literally 10 years
I stopped reading
from the time that I was like
12 to the time that I was like 22
I graduate I like
stopped reading for pleasure
and it was one of my favorite things in the world to do
like last year
I finally read
I've read 38 books
my goal was 40
I didn't make it
but this year
hopefully it will
but like I just read for pleasure
because I could
because I didn't have assignments
I had to do that
were like weighing on me
so I could just
like read again
but also now
I feel like I'm like
so behind in like
the things that I should have
cause I didn't do any of my readings in college
and I didn't do any of my readings in
in high school
because like
my brain didn't want to
but I want to bring those like
I'm interested in them
so now I'm reading the books that I should have read in high school
and in college
I feel like I wasted my degree and I like
wasted my time
because I didn't
learn as much as I could have
because I have the desire to learn
I want to know but like
my brain just like
wasn't meant to do it in an academic setting
like my ADHD also affected my disorder eating
like I was binge eating in high school because um
I didn't have enough dopamine
and food is the easiest way to increase your dopamine
but like if I had just
if I had just dealt with my ADHD
it's just this has been
the most difficult part of my life
the most disabling thing in my life is my ADHD
and it's just so
heartbreaking
and more than anything
the thing that I I
I regret the most
is that like
I've let it affect my like
relationship
I have had so many friends
business partners
brands like lose
broke relationships with them
burnt bridges
just because
I'm incapable of answering
emails and DMs
and texts and
like whatever
like my closest friends
the only way that they can communicate with me
is through Facetime
because I literally
I don't know
I think it's
pathological
demand avoidance
I'm not sure if
I think that's what it's called
but I just like I
I literally am like
I can't do anything that I am supposed to do
and so I have burnt
so many bridges
unintentionally
because of my brain
and just my it's
like and it's so
so stupid like
responding but it's so
it gets so overwhelming
and every day I like
sit here and I just
I think about like
the people that like
I no longer have in my life or like
the connections that I
can no longer rely on
because I ruined that relationship
and also like
people probably think I hate them
because I'm not
responding cause if I
text to someone
and they didn't respond to me
I would think that they hate me
but I do the same thing
and it just like it
it's just my brain
so I have to apologize to every single
new person that I ever meet and be like
I'm so sorry I can't I
I can't text
like call me anyways
I'm sorry I'm like I
I'm sorry for
the big rant
but I guess reminder that ADHD
is a disability
like that's what it is
and I think because you know
everyone deals with it differently
and I think it looks different
in different people
and like I think
because so many
people have it
we forget but like
ADHD is a disability
and it is a disabling
thing to live with
I don't know I I
I would like to find
the right meds
cause vyvance
like it works
obviously a little bit
but like not
well enough and I
I need to find new meds
that I can actually get
and that actually like
work anyways
if you have ADHD
let the serve as a reminder
that you are definitely not alone